four months into the pandemic officials
began publishing the weekly R number it
became the defining statistic for a
government claiming to be guided by the
science
ah is the average number of people one
infected person passes a virus onto at
the height of the pandemic R was useful
describing in one statistic the number
of future infections expected to arise
from each new case
from now on says the UK Health Security
Agency while it will continue to monitor
kovid publishing R is no longer
necessary
this time last year we were approaching
the peak of the Omicron wave of
coronavirus infections yet booster doses
were only beginning to have a
significant impact on protecting people
yet the r number was exactly the same
then as it is now so how meaningful is
that statistic anymore
firstly it's not that accurate a measure
anymore there's a number of people being
tested for Coronavirus has dropped
massively
at a Peak at the end of last year nearly
4 million were tested in a week
at the start of December this year it
was just over a hundred thousand
routine testing stopped as the threat of
covid waned this week around a thousand
people each day are being admitted to
hospital with covid but that's less than
half than at the beginning of 2021
and the number of people dying from
covid is now even lower more than six
times less than at Christmas last year
if the situation would have changed
would it deteriorate then as long as
somebody responds or the government
responds then that's okay publishing the
data in the sort of granularity we have
at the moment we don't have for other
infections like flu or RSV or indeed
group a strep so uh it's not really
necessary and not something we would
normally expect
with a regular update on R be missed
among those enjoying a boxing day walk
about time I mean
um I think we kind of know that not as
many people getting it people are fed up
I think people just really want to have
fun and just they just fed up with it I
think having good data and having a good
understanding of the things that's
happening is always a good idea but I
think you know there has to be some kind
of
um understanding of what it means to be
able to live
given other viruses are now of equal or
greater concern in the UK it arguably
makes sense to shift some Focus from
covid but the surge of infections in
China as it abandons its zero covered
policy serves as a reminder that this
virus is far from done and tracking its
spread remains a priority Tom Clark Sky
News